the jurgen experience i know you love
freedom and i love freedom that's why we
both live in this country but
it's not a fair fight if if and i'm not
against i'm not
a conspiracy guy or but like i was on
wall street
and if you're a burger king you're at
one of these big public companies that's
making food that's not so healthy like
you got scientists you got madison
avenue
advertisers you figured out a way to get
into our
psyche yeah where you can't live without
that thing yeah
right so that's not a fair fight yeah
and they're they're in there and they're
not getting out right but they used to
be able to advertise for cigarettes
they can't do that anymore they stopped
that it's interesting because you could
still
advertise for like jack-in-the-box but
you can't advertise for cigarettes
but obesity kills as many people as
almost anything so that's what i'm
saying would you cross the line
like were you annoyed that you can't
advertise for cigarettes is that taking
away freedom
it's a good question it's a discussion
the problem with those ads is a lot of
them
were at least initially very deceptive
you know
they made it look like marble a man yeah
marble man
i wanted i wanted i wanted to be warm up
yeah right the guy died of cancer by the
way
um so i mean there's no ads where you
see these shitty foods
um with obese people getting sick no
no right they're making you feel good
yeah i wonder if like for every good ad
you would have to have a bad ad like
you'd have to
add i like that like so like for every
good ad for burger king
had you could hire like a company
that would make a creative very
compelling ad
showing fat people having heart attacks
and literally like
[ __ ] or even or even a motivating one to
do something healthy
yeah that would be better the the best
motivation is always positive right but
sometimes not for some people
particularly for people that are
addicted sometimes the wake up is death
door
you get to death's door you have that
heart attack you're like oh my god i
gotta [ __ ] clean up my life
ct yeah right you know i mean
i think ct had underlying um genetic
genetic conditions which many many
people do have it's not even their fault
they just have uh for whatever reason
they just have a
history genetic history of heart disease
heart disease is very weird but it
certainly was exacerbated and he'll tell
you that by his diet
yes that was the doesn't mean you're
definitely gonna die because your
parents did of that right you could you
could
make some lifestyle choices yes yes you
could strengthen your health for sure
in multiple ways
[Applause]